maintenant je n'ai pas quatre ans je ne
suis pas dans la cour de récréation
d'une école vous n'êtes pas mon
instituteur on va pas faire du bourg dun
quel est le prix du ticket de métro ben
ouais je préfère ne pas répondre que de
vous dire des âneries mais je vais
réfléchir à la question et je vous
répondrai le plus complètement possible
et si mes services peuvent dès à présent
vous répondre ils me feront passer la
note je voulais lire et et je vous
rassure m je vous promets qu'il y aura
une réponse à cette question qui vous
tient tellement à coeur elle n'est pas
secondaire monsieur le ministre
elle ne dit pas qu'elle n'est pas
secondaire je ne tirais pas de mon
silence de cet instant je ne sais quelle
conclusion c'est une non réponse
voilà un vrai et puis on est quand même
vous faire remarquer gentiment que
sentiments naturellement je vous être
toujours gentil un hibou nous périmètre
d'intervention sur ce texte limite les
articles dont j'ai parlé sont limitées
bon maintenant on pouvait m'interroger
sur tout ce que vous voulez et si la
démonstration c'est de ne pas obtenir de
réponse
ce n'est pas le but alors je vous
répondrais vous viendrez me voir je vous
répondrais voilà alors si je vais
répondre aux questions auxquelles je je
je pense pouvoir répondre pardon allez
c'est d'abord celle